e anche quest'anno realizzerò qualcosa
di perfetto di preciso e meticoloso
iniziamo subito le ragazze quando fanno
l'albero
iscriviti al canale per non perdere
neanche un video l'albero è alto 216
centimetri e profondo 113 le palline
sono circa 195 vanno dai 2 ai 5 cm di
diametro a seconda della tipologia
quindi per far sì che le palline siano
equidistanti tra di loro
basterà posizionarsi a circa 10,86
centimetri l'una dall'altra perfetto
perfetto palle l'otto dicembre
[Musica]
io non ho voglia di fare l'albero ma
cosa mi è venuto in mente di prendere un
albero così bros
adesso devo aprirlo tutto io da sola
perché nessuno mi aiuta vero nessuno va
bene ti do una mano io arrivato il
principino ascolta non si fa così allora
guarda lascia perdere io li apro così
vedi così si fa tu li apre così non va
bene vai via faccio tutto io tanto in
questa casa come sempre le pulizie
l'albero tutto io mamma senza scala non
riesce arrivare in punta vanno a
prendere fatta quante volte te lo devo
dire le palline grosse vanno in basso e
riprendi più piccole vanno in alto è
tommy gentilmente quella pallina oro con
quei piccoli disegnini a forma
elicoidale melas posti di 7 centimetri
in basso è di 15 verso destra perché c'è
uno spazio che non mi piace per niente
fufi non è che se sei un gatto non puoi
partecipare alla realizzazione
famigliare dell'albero ognuno al suo
compito il tuo quest'oggi è quello di
prendere tutti i gancetti che cadono
accidentalmente dall'albero i cancelli
delle palline ovviamente e nascondono
sotto questo tappeto
ok io odio al natale figurati se mi
metto a fare uno stupido albero che
serve solo ad accumulare polvere
per non parlare di quando lo devi
smontare gli farò crasse risate a vedere
gli altri che fa d'età
non lo so c'è qualcosa che non mi
convince loro 100 da 100 incolore freddo
io sono un autunno
poiché era che tutti questi anni ho
sbagliato i colori delle palline
dell'albero è quello che quando pubblica
pur le foto insieme all'albero prendevo
pochissimi like perché non rientrano
nella mia palette colori via basta
adesso esco e vado a comprare delle
fantastiche palline oro eros maledetti
rami di marta vi pongo dovuta io mi
chiedo chi ha inventato queste maledette
lucine perché da due ora che ci giro
intorno a dedalo di tanto ci sono tutte
quanto ci vuole a finire questo nome
gettò il brano amo oggi niente piscina
perché sta facendo l'albero non ci
giornata dedicata all'albero e lo sai
che io faccia sempre prima amore lo so
che siamo così riusciti agosto ma per me
dopo ferragosto è già natale ed
automatico non lo so manca ancora
qualcosa
e perfetto sta benissimo ha detto così a
mo di l'irlanda ma ma questa maglietta
di mia sorella è perfetta si abbina
perfettamente all'albero allora basta
fare una pallina così info raggomitolata
ma che non accorge infine ciliegina
sulla torta la punta è originario
dell'europa
guarda che bella eppure ricicla tutto
vestito di halloween ma l'originalità ma
la sentite nell'aria io ho davvero
perfetto questo albero è pura magia ma
ma anche il pezzo forte
i bambi barbosi sa che questa rosa è un
perfetto microfono genova o swing blues
rock
ecco questo campo sempre
[Applauso]
malagrotta di mio amore ho fatto vecchia
che c'è il papa è sei tu ma che bello ma
guarda bravissima è bellissimo
tieni grazie grazie amore ma tieni per
metterlo nei a me lo sa e guarda amore
l'albero la mamma ci ha messo tanto
impegno e vedi non c'è più posto
il disegno è tutto pieno bellissimo
pieno
hai detto con tutto il cuore che non ti
piace papà e mio amore mio va bene amore
mio non piangere è appendiamo il tuo
disegno sull'albero
[Musica]